to change one more finessing great this
[Music]
[Applause]
it's to the first yeah definitely no
middleman to chains mister to my closest
friends they call me deuce that's me
mister torture ranges from 7,000 to
$14,000 [ __ ] yeah this $48,000 $10,000
Martine $295 with or without tax or
fries oh right you've never yours the
car the dirt on this car alone is worth
20,000 damn you rich yeah it's a bargain
here's what I've learned in this
business
everything's relative you cannot buy
this anywhere except it broke loose
Lounge and I heard that as you're seeing
it it's $260,000 it's 260 yeah
bands like you would say bang 260 bands
Hana Hana Hana thought pay you Alejandra
write down what followed it yeah you
know what followed it the other 15
whenever we see my music is geometry
it's mathematic $10,000 for something
that takes four days and make which only
takes one minute to break here's the
thing I don't know and I could see me
[ __ ] up my checkbook to
Haiti's smoke please keep pull this
whole thing out [ __ ]
dr. Dana put an ounce allowed in here
leave my John this is getting miss Emily
sage is just like it raises the
vibration you gotta take a hit kind of
what this does exactly weeds out all
kind of the negative energy
he told me alighted oh yeah
[Music]
I don't even know how my rep is uh
breathing let's wrap up another joint
that's what we're gonna do
always having the munchies like ice
cream sundae a damn hamburger darling
this is coming Milton I just a some gold
on the rocks
I changed the lawyer they tell you like
a Rolex I go out to eat a lot and I take
a lot of the silverware with me that's
just my thing I have a ship with me at
all times
mmm I'm this hip-hop icon and we happen
to actually be you know friends we cool
we talk about you know women and dances
and song
hey micro micro put it down somewhere
right on brother
yeah that's right brother we got you
right that's right it's the movement sit
there somewhere
one time rap thing is going excellent
for me put if not I'm a hook up with you
all right and you can sling some ice
cream bang all right so look if it's
possible to riot on